The 12,018 she would enter Canada is out.
Now you can order the limited edition
for the short time of 10 days and then
never again.
It's like a regular calendar for 2018
but with one important difference.
It's for the year 12,018
of the human error.
We explained why they should be our
current year in our a new calendar for
humanity video.
Last year's calendar got a lot of feedback
and we listened to what she wanted.
The 12,018 calendar has much more
room for notes, a spiral binding.
We got the shipping costs down and
it will arrive in time for Christmas.
It's printed on high quality paper has
a gold cover and it was produced in
Seattle so we could ensure
codes cause aren't quality.
The calendar itself features 12 detailed
illustrations of human cultures around
the world.
Order it now.
It's available for the limited time
of 10 days until October the 20th the
Schumann,
Eric Canada is a passion project for us
that represents the idea of human unity
and progress,
and that we need to work together to
stay alive and to travel to the stars.
It's the second time we've made one
and we're trying to make this a regular
thing. Thanks a lot to everyone who
loves the idea of a new history.
We couldn't do any of this without this
group of likeminded humans around the
world.
Yeah.